[Musique]
il y à 50 ans le général leclerc
recevait la reddition du général von
choltitz le commandant du gross parisse
un moment inoubliable dans la libération
de la france
quatre ans presque jour pour jour après
le désastre
mais le général de gaulle avait prédit
que la force mécanique qui nous avait
vaincu trouverez un jour contre elle une
force mécanique supérieure
ce sont ces blindés des chars de leclerc
qui ont libéré paris et contribuer à la
victoire finale et ce sont les blindés
qui aujourd'hui encore sont le fer de
lance de notre défense c'est pourquoi
cette histoire s'appelle de leclerc ou
leclerc
mais comment comprendre cette aventure
comment saisir cette extraordinaire
révolution technologique et militaire
que représente le char leclerc sans
revoir cette histoire celle des blindés
tels que le magnifique musée de saumur
permet de la survoler bonjour bienvenue
dans ce qui j'espère sera jour le plus
beau musée des blindés
nous sommes ici au bâtiment général
estienne le père des chats devant nous
avons exposé à certains nombre de
véhicules mais je pense qu on comprendra
mieux ce qu'est l'évolution du charron
rentrer à l'intérieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le directeur du musée le colonel
patrick olney le début des chars dans la
première guerre mondiale fut assez
folklorique où est le problème et à
celui des tranchées les barbelés
c'est une brouette avec meetic une
brouette blaney vous avez ici une forme
de viser avec même des obturateurs pour
éviter qu'éventuellement ils prennent
des éclats et ça nous permettait quand
même de voir où ils pouvaient progresser
c'est le char humains oui non
reconnaissant bush caractéristiques du
75 c'est un des premiers chars est
composé de sept premiers c'est qu'à la
minute
alors c'est de saint-chamond qui a été
envisagée aux envions 1917 il a été
engagé pour la première fois en 1917
ce saint chamond c'était le char de 75
me dans une carcasse posés sur des
chenilles qui punit caterpillar de deux
tracteurs mais vous voyez que finalement
son son pied était un peu petit et il y
avait un peu un porte à faux sur l'avant
ce qui fait qu'il y avait un moyen qui
permettait de passer dans la tranchée
alors ce moyen on peut le voir quand on
est à l'intérieur
vous voyez ce petit rouleau type
tonnelet sutton les prenait appui sur le
bord de la tranchée et permettait de ne
pas rester au fond il y en a un de
chaque côté là on voit bien dans cette
évolution des chars
on est vraiment en pleine archaïsme
c'est en fait c'est une grande carcasse
de ferraille avec deux dents sur des
chenilles de tracteurs avec un canon de
75 qu'elle était l'efficacité
il permettait de traverser les tranchées
il permettait
avec son canon de faire sauter des
bunkers adverse c'est d'ailleurs la même
chose qu'on retrouve sur le schneider à
côté vous trouvez pour faire sauter les
barbelés
cet éperon qui permettait de cisailler
les barbelés
là nous avons donc les deux premiers
chars ce qui les caractérise c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas de tourelles et bien
maintenant un char extraordinaire je
crois que c'est le le plus célèbre
peut-être de cette époque qui lui
comprend pour la première fois une cure
elle sait cela on est arrivé au ft 17
construit par renault ce petit char
était servie par deux hommes le pilote à
l'avant est derrière vous aviez l'homme
orchestre
c'était le chef de char qui était en
même temps les coûts de son capitaine
qui est en même temps donneurs d'ordres
pour son pilote qui était chargeurs qui
était tireurs ont tiré il ya une tunique
sang il n'y avait pas encore
d'extracteurs de fumée n'y avait pas
encore de filtrage d'air il n'y avait
pas encore d'optique
regardez quand on ferme voyez à peu près
ce que pouvait être la vision du pilote
ou du chef de char
[Musique]
le pilote ne voyez que par cette petite
fente dans les améliorations des chars
on a fait un saut prodigieux le jour on
a pu mettre de l'optique
ce qui fait qu'on voit aussi bien à
l'intérieur d'un char comme si on était
à l'extérieur
là on a une tourelle qui est
intermédiaire bien sûr autre celle des
u17 le répit sur toutes celles que sera
le clair et surtout ce qu'on voit bien
c'est l'optique les optiques les
optiques on est à l'intérieur un tour et
l'eau où il est le chef de char allaoua
périscope on voit parfaitement dans ce
type de chat les grandes étapes de
l'évolution des charges fille hélas par
la guerre et dans la guerre
les hordes de panzers 3 nazis lâché dans
le désert avec l'afrique accord après
avoir vaincu les chars de l'armée
française de 40
les sommes à b1 hotchkiss bon matériel
très mal employé après avoir vaincu
aussi les chars anglais matilda au
church in sorte de château fort roulant
avec laure murat et verticale
vulnérables aux obus allemands
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
invincible les marques gap avance vers
moscou
en 1941 contre les russes lancent un
remarquable matériel le meilleur char
sans doute de toute la guerre le thé 34
[Musique]
c'est le capitaine jean-pierre tributes
conservateur du musée qui nous présente
cette perle de sa collection est devant
vous le premier t34 ayant apparu sur
champ de bataille c'est à dire armé d'un
canon de 76 mm il faut voir que la
construction est très rudimentaire
c'était les femmes en fin de compte qui
la légine il faisait les soudures et
autres une plate forme de travail est
mal mais les pauvres et aubier mise à
rude épreuve donc ensuite par rapport à
sa charge on a vite amélioré prenez le
char que vous sa gauche t34 avec canon
de 85 mm la partie intéressante et ce
bradage profiler c'est un char robuste
fiable et très rapide
on pourrait même sur un air de valse le
faire puis aux boîtes et dans tous les
sens dans cette salle donc par rapport à
ce charme
les allemands se sont trouvés un moment
piégés lancés les secrets ignorer la
construction de ce thé 34 et c'est de là
qu'on a provoqué la fabrication du
panthère et duty loin
[Musique]
alors mon capitaine
ce char c'est mentir le point final de
l'évolution du char pendant la guerre
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est le plus
extraordinaire le plus grand le plus
formidable sharks et gbt construit le
tigre royal
en fin de compte cette année cher que la
production la technologie allemand elle
a pu sortir c'est un engin de 70 tonnes
est mue par un moteur de 700 chevaux
malheureusement car les allemands n'ont
pas pu mettre au point à temps le moteur
de 1000 chevaux je l'avais prévu
140 88 en fin de compte était invincible
et son blindage le rendait à vulnérable
par rapport à toutes les armes qu'il y
avait en face son seul problème a résidé
à la fin le
la fin de sa vie un manque d'essence de
carburant commençait la grande bataille
tigre et panthères ont succombé sous le
nom les milliers de sherman des
divisions blindées américaine combien
ont connu le sort de ceux panthères le
tireur qui est en face aux chars est un
très très beau pointer pense qu'on peut
dénombrer un coup ici qui a traversé le
bien là le faible la daj un coup ici
qu'à traverser ce barrage frontale ça
fait 2-1 coûts ainsi qu'à ricochet 3 4 5
6 1 7e qui reste est fiché là dedans et
peut-être un qui aurait fait éclater
alors c'est alors voilà c'est là
n'oublie qui rentrait bloqué alors en
fin de compte on peut dire que ce ce
groupement de coûts à désolidariser en
fin de compte les sous du halage il a
arrêté il n'arrête t il à arrêter mais
on a une photo où on voit que c'est un
équipage français qui le ramène dans
l'eau les nids espère qu'il connaît bien
marché donc il continue toujours j'ai
effectivement le système de direction
ici le coup est passé au dessus ça ne va
pas casser
bon et puis après les pouces sont perdus
dans la casemate et ça n'a pas été plus
loin nous irons au bout de combien de
coups il continue encore à marcher on
compte on compte six à sept coups de
parler des formes de ric hochet
l'équipage était pas l'équipe à
l'équipage on ne parle pas de l'équipage
est juste la photo madame
du chef d'un chef de char français
marchant devant et a certainement la
pilote et le ramène chez lui dans le
propos comment est-ce qu'on analyse
toute cette vision des chats de faire
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
on est passé d'un petit char de ce genre
parce que le plaisir
le petit char de la guerre de 14 en face
de lui une avec un fusil antichars de 7
92 mm pour percer son blindage mais que
c'est le fameux duel canon cuirassé donc
il fallait automatiquement vous
augmentez votre jeune âge il faut
automatiquement augmenter le calibre
pour le père c'est donc en fin de compte
les allemands se sont retrouvés à la fin
avec un art vivant un engin qui était
indestructible
on peut pas le toit se passer de face ni
le profil de part son blindage de par
son profil et lui avait par contre la
force de vin que tout ce qu'il avait en
face donc nous arrivons à cette
conclusion que à la fin des années
quarante cinq
il fallait donc des canons de plus en
plus lourd des cuirasses de plus en plus
épaisse
alors on arrivait à quoi les 1 200
tonnes de 100 tonnes
les allemands ont testé on fait même
deux prototypes du fameux sharma aux 100
tonnes comment est-ce qu'on peut tirer
une leçon de toute cette vision des
chars de la confusion on est un peu
difficile à faire puisqu'en fin de la
dernière guerre on se retrouve avec des
monstres de 70 tonnes pour redescendre
après avec avec deux des chars beaucoup
plus mobile
un classement x 13
quelques 15 ans plus tard et on revient
maintenant à notre époque à des engins
de 55 60 tonnes donc c'est toujours ce
fameux problème et un char c'est un
calibre c'est un blindage mais aussi
c'est une motorisation et on ne peut pas
avoir et à la fois un gros blindage et
un gros canon parce qu'à ce moment là il
faut un trop gros moteur ça nous fera un
monstre donc il faut faire un compromis
entre ces trois critères
est ce qu'avec le leclerc on est arrivé
à une sorte de perfection
je pense qu'avec ce chat on arrive à vue
la puissance moteur du sans blindage du
son armement et son système
d'environnement et de tirs
actuellement c'est certainement le
meilleur char sur le marché mondial le
leclerc est aussi le produit d'une
longue lignée d'excellents chars de
combat les à mx avec d'abord un très
intéressant prototype d'après guerre la
amy 50 puis les matériels des divisions
blindées de l'armée française de la mx
13 à la mx 30 dans le contexte de des
forces nucléaires il a fallu trouver un
char qui était étanche aux radiations au
nucléaire qui avait une puissance de feu
supérieure avec un canon de 105 par
rapport aux 40 90 donc on est arrivé sur
ce char qui a équipé pratiquement toutes
les divisions et qui continue encore en
équipe et quelques-unes camarades qui
sont partis dans le golfe avec ce type
de matériel je crois en beauté très
satisfait mais la mise en service de
cette à mx 30 au milieu des années 60
l'état-major s'est inquiété de savoir
par quoi il pouvait un jour être
remplacé la ville un char peut être de
20 minutes en temps de guerre de vingt
ans en temps de paix dans cette dernière
hypothèse les militaires des années 60
se poser la question de ce que pourrait
être ce qu'ils appelaient l'engin
principal de combat serait ce même un
chat un hélicoptère un ange à hyper
sophistiqué à effet de sol
une arme encore inconnue tout cela selon
l'évolution des technologies et de la
menace les militaires qu'on vire les
ingénieurs à réfléchir avec eux de 1969
à 1977
en huit ans de travaux tout sur
convaincu qu'il fallait bien un char et
que ce devait être un char lourd c'est à
cette même conclusion qu'ils étaient
parvenus les américains avec le m1 les
russes avec le t 72
les anglais avec le challenger les
allemands avec les léopards 2 mais tous
étaient des projets assez conventionnel
sauf le chien s suédois une conception
tout à fait particulière il n'y a pas de
tourelles la direction et donner
automatiquement par les chenilles
ils ont fait un petit peu comme les
israéliens ont fait le merkava le
merkava est un char qui a été fait pour
leur combat nous on ne voit pas le
merkava mon avis combattre en europe
c'est pas tout à fait le même théâtre la
même utilisation ils ont conçu pour
leurs problèmes de défense a eu
d'ailleurs même ils ont même sur les
patins jeune et si vous voulez on voit
que ces gens là on ne travaille que dans
la glace les chenilles vous avez des
petites pointes qui sont qu'ils sont qui
ressorte et de chaque pépin qui sont
peut être agressif pour accrocher la
glace et leur terrain les français sont
gèrent eux aussi au milieu de bien
d'autres possibilités
un char 100 tours est une disposition
vite jugé difficile d'emploi car le
souci numéro un était de réduire la
surface frontale pour rendre le char
moins vulnérables et moins repérables il
fallait créer une tourelle la plus
compacte et la plus plate possible
la solution un équipage réduit avec un
système de chargement automatique
mais pas n'importe lequel celui ci
devait être intelligent il devait
pouvoir reconnaître les munitions
etions-nous capable de mettre au point
un tel matériel
comment motorisés la future tour elle de
18 ans n'a sciemment les solutions
furent trouvés à chaque détour de cette
passionnante exploration
les ingénieurs se trouvait confronté à
des choix exemple comment placer le
moteur
en fait il faudra aller jusqu'à inventer
un nouveau genre de moteur
c'était le moteur hyperbare un procédé
de suralimentation inventé pour le
leclerc et qui devait un jour fournir
une puissance sans équivalent de 1500
chevaux pour seulement 16 litres 4 de
cinabre et ses choix vont être parfois
très audacieux celui du tout numérique
par exemple nous semblent aujourd'hui
évidents pour l'époque il ne l'était pas
mais pas du tout quinze ans plus tard il
représente l'atout capital de ce
matériel avec son adaptabilité sa
fiabilité ses concurrents s'essouffle à
faire évoluer leurs calculateurs mais le
leclerc a une bonne longueur d'avancé la
clé les programmes nous dit un grand
spécialiste
monsieur jean maillet du musée des
blindés de saumur oui maintenant le
système leclerc ont dit que le père
trois hommes d'équipage
c'est pas vrai le leclerc a plus que
trois hommes parce qu'il est en
permanence en liaison avec l'extérieur
avec son chef de peloton avec son chef
de l'escadron avec sans sa logistique
avec ses camarades qui sont à droite et
à gauche
il ya donc plus que d'autres que trois
hommes dans un leclerc ainsi le leclerc
a été dès le début conçu autour de
l'idée capitale devait tronic
c'est-à-dire de véhicules électroniques
toute architecture du char est axée sur
une colonne vertébrale informatique qui
gère en temps réel toutes les
informations intérieur et extérieur à
partir de là on a commencé à donner une
quatrième dimension vous cher puisqu'il
y en avait trois jusqu'à maintenant qui
était leur l'armement la mobilité et la
protection
on lui a donné un quatrième dimension
qui est le système le système consistant
à laisser le cher un peu plus libre faut
pas oublier que l'on met moins de monde
au kilomètre carré maintenant dans un
lieu de combat qu'on en mettra 10
puisqu'il fallait quelque chose comme 5
mm
cinq mille hommes à napoléon pour un air
pur kilomètres carrés maintenant on en
compte deux cent cinquante les véhicules
c'est exactement la même chose mais
il faut également ne pas oublier que le
cheikh doit être absolument soutenu aidé
par un environnement et par ses voisins
ccc ses voisins ses camarades cesser les
chairs de son côté et ça a été la grosse
invention de des années 80 72 80 la
quatrième dimension donner aux chères en
1982 les grandes options ont été prises
reste à les mettre au point comme par
exemple tout le système de roulement
chenille transmission conduit dans un
tel projet ce n'est pas une mince
affaire
le char devra aller très vite sans que
l'équipage soit trop malmenée dans sa
carcasse d'acier
[Musique]
il va falloir choisir entre deux types
de suspension l'une mécanique l'autre
oléopneumatique deux équipes vont les
essayer en concurrence une longue
souffrance pour les matériels et les
hommes vous pourrez en juger sur ces
images il se passe de commentaires
[Musique]
lui
il
[Musique]
c'est l'équipe de l'eau les eaux
pneumatiques qui gagnera en démontrant
avec beaucoup de courage que l'on
pouvait aller plus loin dans l'extrême
résistance tout en restant stable pour
le tir le tir c'est telle affaire d'une
autre équipe
pendant que les pilotes prenait tous les
risques sur tous les terrains le à
satory montait la première tour elle est
en ce beau jour d'octobre 1986 les
bouches du futur charles leclerc sortait
de l'atelier
[Musique]
il avait effectué son premier tir c'est
une tradition
essayez le canon pour voir s'il tient
ensemble mais avec une télécommande
on ne sait jamais ensuite toute l'équipe
s'acharnera à perfectionner le matériel
c'est ce qui est très original dans
cette épopée industrielle
l'idée constante d'adapter le concept de
le faire évoluer sans cesse mais comment
en construisant comme nos concurrents et
à grands frais de trop nombreux
prototypes non le giat choisira de
définir ses solutions en simulateur une
réflexion commune avec la direction
générale de l'armement et les militaires
futurs utilisateurs
[Musique]
en fait dans la réalité tout peut bouger
sauf le canon et ses organes de visée
ce sera une nouvelle percée
technologique du leclerc un système de
stabilisation électrique supérieure à
tous les autres
on le voit bien ici le canon toujours
parfaitement pointer quels que soient
les mouvements du chan
tout est prêt maintenant pour la
première grande campagne de tirs 20 86
au centre d'essais des landes avec tous
les objets classiques mais aussi la
munition actuelle la plus terrifiante
l'obus flèche but flèche s'est
communiquée toute l'énergie cinétique au
départ du coup à un barreau qui est donc
d'inciter très importante avec une très
grande vitesse initiale
c'est sous calibre et c'est à dire que
par rapport aux canons vous voyez bien
que c'est très fin au moment du départ
du coup les ailettes ici se déploie
simplement pour donner une trajectoire à
peu près conforme et au moment où on
arrive sur le blindage et bien la
vitesse l'énergie cinétique traverse
[Musique]
quatre mois
les équipes techniques étaient
satisfaites
quelle que soit la position horizontale
incliné en marche sur cibles fixes ou
mobiles
le chargement automatique ou les
équipements avec le fameux bus système
informatique qui les relier entre eux
tout avait parfaitement fonctionné
autrement dit la phase de définition
était terminée en 1987 commencer la
phase de développement avec le lancement
une pré série de six engins qui devait
intégrer toute cette moisson
d'enseignement en attendant les essais
continuer les militaires s'associer aux
tests de validation des performances du
premier char au japon on achevait de
martyriser les premiers châssis
[Musique]
la mécanique devait pouvoir résister au
froid célèbre du camp de mourmelon
ou à la chaleur concentré de camp de
canjuers
et la fameuse suspension oléopneumatique
devait prouver un rassemblement son
efficacité avec le formidable moteur
hyperbare de 1500 chevaux
il devait donner au leclerc une mobilité
sans précédent et pour cause la vitesse
la furtivité la silhouette fait que pour
pouvoir tirer sur le leclerc va falloir
se lever de bonne heure parce qu'il va
aller vite il va se déplacer rapidement
il va pouvoir être vous dit pour ne pas
être tirés faut pas être vu faut pas
être identifié faut pas pouvoir
faux faux ne pas être statique c'est
seulement quand on a réussi toutes ces
conditions qu'on pourra peut-être mettre
un coup du sort de l'eau claire mais
fort à ce très fort au début 89
le général forêt à l'époque chef d'état
major de l'armée de terre bien se rendre
compte de l'avancement des travaux au
printemps ce sont les officiers de la 2e
db qui se déplacent impatient de
connaître ce char qui porte le nom de
leur chef légendaire
tous sont frappés par l'aspect
extraordinaire mans compacte du moteur
pourtant rappelons le de 15 cents
chevaux présentés ici avec sa boîte de
vitesses mais c'est surtout
l'environnement informatique de bord
inconnue à ce jour qu'il est stupéfie et
les commandes type guerre des étoiles
mais les ingénieurs du giat continuent
leur travail obscur et encore sur des
chaînes comme si la conquête du graal
technologique devait toujours être
repoussée avec des obstacles de plus en
plus difficile
démarche de 1 m 10 et sur le terrain de
valdahon près de besançon des acrobaties
qui pourront définitivement rassurer les
militaires sur la solidité de leur futur
matériel
[Musique]
voilà qui aura permis aussi aux mécanos
de vérifier les conceptions de départ
sur la maintenance rapide en campagne 45
minutes pour changer le groupe
motopropulseur un autre record et comme
il se doit cette grande période
d'expérimentation se termine ici par les
essais de freinage tout à fait
spectaculaire
[Musique]
oui rendant hommage à tous ces équipages
décès regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou c'est long et c'est toutes ces années
de recherche de l'excellence et voilà
qu'enfin elles étaient 90 le leclerc est
présenté aux unités au gouvernement au
public aux acheteurs étrangers
[Musique]
c'est
quoi
sur nécessaire
le premier ministre était cet après midi
au camp de biars dans la vienne afin de
saluer l'armée de terre qui avait mis
les petits chars dans les grands pour
présenter au premier ministre le nouvel
à mx leclerc notre nouveau champ de
bataille et bourré d'électronique et n'a
aucun équivalent dans le monde à mes
terres s'adapte très vite aux
technologies les plus modernes si on lui
en donne les moyens
ce qui intéressera le plus les
journalistes françaises ou étrangers
spécialiste de l'armement ou non celle
énoncée des performances
impressionnantes du char tels que les
révèle à ce moment là le constructeur
vitesse plus de 70 kilomètres à l'heure
c'est à dire un objectif furtif
difficile à acquérir et à tirer point
capital sur lequel nos militaires ont
déjà insisté
et nous avons amplement vu que cette
vitesse pouvait rester élevée sur les
pires obstacles
le tout pour une machine de 55 tonnes
armé d'un canon de 120 mm et les
services techniques officiels de la dg à
vos homologué au bout d'une série de
tirs impressionnant à bourges en août
1990 puissance de feu cadence de tir
stabilité et précision portée et
efficacité
tout est validé avec de très élogieux
commentaire
[Musique]
nope lui 7 6
comme sont validés les autres concepts
innovateurs de la machine tous les
moyens informatiques de tir tiffin
leclerc avec la visée infrarouge de nuit
un véritable char tout temps
[Musique]
non
mais leclerc prouve aussi qu'il est seul
capable de tirer de recharger en roulant
avec une précision inégalée
[Musique]
au programme de validation de
performance est terminée les instruments
de mesure sont retirées une nouvelle
phase commence
[Musique]
le programme d'évaluation opérationnel
s'accélère à mourmelon en avril 1991
les militaires ne ménagent pas leurs
montures
[Musique]
en septembre de la même année attends je
verse il s'entraîne à la guerre
[Musique]
on
et
papa
[Musique]
cela demande parfois de rester 24 heures
d'affilée à l'intérieur du char ce que
les officiers des services techniques de
l'armée de terre démontre sans
difficulté le leclerc est confortable
autant que cela soit possible
en tout cas c'est un engin rassurant
pour tous ceux qui seraient un jour
hélas obligé d'aller au combat avec lui
y compris dans les pires hypothèses
celle de l'apocalypse que les militaires
appellent l'environnement nbc nucléaire
bactériologique et chimique
le leclerc pourra continuer c'est là
d'ailleurs que se vérifie la doctrine du
char dans ce genre de conflit ne
serait-il pas le seul à pouvoir occuper
le terrain et tout son système
informatique intégré dans un vaste
réseau donnera en permanence et en temps
réel aux postes de commandement une
masse d'informations inconnue à ce jour
est capitale pour la conduite
stratégique et tactique du combat
moderne
[Musique]
à
c'est ainsi qu'a été conçue est né et a
grandi un instrument de défense
incomparable janvier 1992
madame la maréchale leclerc de
hauteclocque a baptisé le premier char
de série pour l'armée française puis
vint le premier succès à l'exportation
le chars français leclerc a battu le
cheikh américains abrams et le char
britannique challenger tout dans la
bataille économique qui les opposait
dans le golfe persique les émirats
arabes unis l'ont préféré à ses
concurrents occidentaux ils ont trouvé
plus performants et comme les émirats
ont beaucoup d'argent ils en achètent
d'un coup d'un seul 436 nicolas winckler
la partie était pourtant loin d'être
gagnée il ya quelques semaines la france
devait en effet faire face à deux
importants concurrents
les anglais et les américains ce matin
le ministre de la défense des émirats
tranché enfin les émirats arabes unis
ont décidé de se porter acquéreur pour
leurs forces armées de 436 chars leclerc
fabriqués en france dans le gie actes le
char leclerc français a donc dû livrer
bataille à un rival américain
politiquement et militairement très
compétitif
le dessous des cartes ce contrat car la
belle
les sables du désert le char leclerc
connaît déjà ses concurrents américains
abrams et britanniques challenger avait
pour eux la supériorité d'avoir été
engagés dans la guerre du golfe mais le
leclerc a pour lui l'avantagé
déterminant de la technologie de tout
dernier cri en accueillant
l'international defence exhibition les
émirats arabes unis montrent qu'ils sont
des acheteurs exigeants n'hésitant pas à
faire jouer la concurrence sur des
questions techniques et plus seulement
sur les affinités politiques
bonjour un contrat en or pour la france
les commandes pour l'industrie française
de l'armement nouvelle pour l'industrie
française
un contrat en or pour giat industries le
jackpot 436 chars français leclerc la
libération évalué à 21 milliards de
francs le contrat signé entre la france
et les émirats un contrat camions qui
représente selon françois une manne de
33 milliards divergences plus optimiste
encore le figaro estime que la vente des
436 chars leclerc aux émirats unis
rapportera 34 milliards cette fois à la
france et assurera 5 millions d'heures
de travail à jihâd industrie qui
construit des engins mais échos avancent
encore d'autres chiffres 21 milliards
pour ce contrat militaire exceptionnel
mais 11 millions d'heures de travail
pour les arsenaux terrestres et leur
sous-traitant qui devrait avoir du
boulot jusque environ l'an 2000 mais
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là l'énorme
effort de recherche et de développement
n'est pas terminée déjà s'élaborent les
commandes vocales le blindage évolutif
et bien d'autres secrets technologie
encore jalousement gardé et puis surtout
c'est une grande aventure industrielle
qui continue le puissant groupement
d'armement terrestre est devenu en 1990
une société nationale j ai hâte
industrie avec les moyens de sa réussite
comme le mirage comme l'airbus comme le
tgv
le leclerc représente une démonstration
de ce que peut la france
quel chemin parcouru de leclerc pour
leclerc
[Musique]
g
m
[Musique]
nos côtés mais c'est un sac